This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk
through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology hello everybody welcome back to the show welcome back to the podcast new listeners old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. When we think of friendships, I'd hope most of us think of these very glorious relationships, like the reason the world spins, the most glorious moments of laughter and conversation and like someone who you don't have to explain yourself to and like ultimate comfortability. friendship is obviously supposed to be kind of a place of like ease and safety and joy.
But sometimes, you know, let's just say it very simply, it just isn't. Sometimes a friendship does start to feel more like an obligation or a drain or a source of anxiety. Unfortunately, for those who have, you know, those of us who have been in this situation, some friendships can become very toxic and show patterns of control and disrespect and manipulation that do a number on us, really start to chip away at our self-esteem. And that brings me to the focus of today's episode. Obviously, we are talking about toxic friendships, specifically the five types of toxic friendships that you will encounter, not just in your 20s, but I think in life in general.
I obviously love focusing on like the beauty of friendship and like how wonderful it is and how much it brings us. And I'm kind of always a little bit bummed to talk about the less positive sides of friendship. But it does need to be acknowledged. We are so good at talking about red flags and relationships, signs of toxic or narcissistic partners. But platonic relationships are just as important and therefore can sometimes be just as difficult and harmful. And in your 20s, I think this is even more complicated. Friendship means so much to us in this decade. But also your life is rapidly changing.
And sometimes our friendships don't match up with what else is happening in our life. Maybe you've had or you have found success and suddenly this relationship has become competitive. Or your friend's made new friends and now it's one side it. Now it's rooted in criticism. Now you're no longer supporting each other. Here's the truth. Not every friendship is meant to last forever. Yet we so often hold on because friendship is wrapped up in these ideas of loyalty and longevity.
And I think at the end of the day, hope. We all have this image. We've all talked to our friends about being in each other's weddings, knowing each other's children, being in the nursing home together. And so when that becomes obvious that that's not going to be the future, it can feel like a betrayal. But sometimes it is absolutely necessary. And quite frankly, worth it to acknowledge when a friendship is no longer suiting us or when it has turned toxic. So today we're going to talk about that, the five types of toxic friendships that we might encounter, how to recognize them, how to know when you're in one, how to navigate getting out of one, especially when you're in like a broader friendship group. And when it is absolutely time to walk away, time to say just goodbye.
And how to do that. There's quite a lot, I've realized. There's a lot to talk about, but I am ready. I hope you are too. Without further ado, let's get into it. If you think back to being a child, you know, your world was relatively small. Like the people who mattered to you are like your family and like the neighborhood kids or like the kids you go to school with. They weren't really chosen. They're just kind of there. Same thing in adolescence. Maybe they matter a little bit more. But it's definitely tied up in like school and proximity. Your 20s are very different. Everything kind of splinters. You meet so many new people. This is the decade where you truly choose a lot of those meaningful relationships. And those choices make a
huge difference. You might be living away from family, living in a new city where you don't know anyone. You're figuring out who you are. And your friends become the scaffolding for that new sense of self. it's why this decade gets called the friendship decade mainly by me but i'm trying to get it to catch on you know you're not tied down by the same responsibilities that take over later on like marriage kids big career investments big financial investments but you also aren't like the main relationship you have isn't the one you have with your family anymore friends step into this empty space left by family and before you know kids or a major life partner steps in and they become everything to us. They become like family. I know that sounds so cringe, but we know that's
the truth. We know that they are more important in this decade than any other. And there's good reason for this. A 2023 study published in Frontiers in Psychology actually demonstrated that adult friendships are the strongest predictor of life satisfaction for young adults, even more than career success, finances, or romantic status. That's crazy. It means that, you know, the person sitting across from you at the cafe right now or the person in your group chat has more of an influence on your well-being and whether you're going to be happy than almost anything else right now. A healthy friendship gives us psychological safety, first of all. It gives us a space where we can be confused and we can be messy and we can be ambitious or we can be vulnerable without fear
being judged and I think they also give us a mirror. You know, we really see ourselves reflected and how our friends respond to us. When a friend tells us they're proud of you, you know, that gives you a boost when they tell you to kind of pull your head in, that humbles you, you see yourself through them. And friendship, which I don't think a lot of people know, actually regulates us biologically. The neuroscientist Ruth Feldman has conducted a lot of research in this area and her work has shown that close friends that spend time together, their physiological states literally sink up. Their heart rates align, their bodies release oxytocin in tandem, their brain activity shows similar patterns. This is a phenomenon called bio-behavioral synchrony. And it explains why
being near a trusted friend can and will significantly lower your stress levels. I have this with a couple of my friends, but I'm really thinking about my best friend. I surprised her recently in Tasmania, which is like this tiny island off of Australia where she lives. And every time I'm around her, we always talk about how calm and co-regulated we feel. Like everything just feels lighter and easier and softer. In other words, you know, really great friendships don't just make life enjoyable. They actually make you a more stable version of yourself. So that's why when a friendship tips into like unhealthy territory, the damage can feel so destabilizing. Because in essence, you know, you're not just losing a relationship, you're losing a co-regulator,
you're losing a mirror, you're losing a source of strength. So with that in mind, let's dive into these five types of toxic friendships to look out for. Firstly, I want to just give a brief caveat. What do we mean when we actually say by toxic? I don't think that toxic describes a person. I'm using it to describe a relationship. I fully believe this. I don't think that anyone can be toxic. We all have character traits and flaws that someone else won't like, but other people won't have an issue with.
There are some people that maybe are more malicious and manipulative than others. It doesn't mean that they are inherently a poisonous person. I also believe people inherently have a capacity to change. That's my personal belief. there are things in my past that I'm not entirely proud of. There are moments that I have let someone down and I've done the wrong thing. Absolutely. Like I can remember these times when I didn't think about someone else's feelings and that really hurt them.
But I know I have grown and I've acknowledged my role and my actions. And that has really helped me have this new perspective for friends that have hurt me in the past. It's not always fair to judge someone based on the last impression you had of them. them five years ago, 10 years ago. We change so much in that time, especially if you were like under the age of 30 when it happened. I think only true sociopaths can be labeled as toxic and even then some of them are very functional and they learn empathy and they are no different to you and me in terms of how they act in friendships. So what we are referring to here is toxic dynamics. and the friction that can be created between two people because of how one person is acting, another person is responding, their environment and how their personalities may be clashing.
So I just want to clear that up at the top. That being said, let's introduce the first type of toxic friendship, the competitor. For this type of friend or friendship, everything feels like they're trying to one up you. you got a new job? Well, that doesn't compare at all to their promotion that they had last month. You just ran 5K? Well, they're training for a 10K, so good luck with that. If you've gone to London, they went to Paris.
Each time you share successes or something you're proud of, their knee-jerk reaction is to match it, beat it, or downplay it. Even suffering can become a contest. I don't know if you've experienced this, but you know what that one-jerkers? friend where if you're stressed, they're more stressed. If you're hurt, they're hurting worse. If they've been through a breakup, well, you should hear about their breakup from five years ago. It was awful. This isn't just annoying. Over time, it really erodes your ability to share
anything with them. Because why would you? Why would you if they're just going to turn it into a competition? The root of this is usually social comparison, right? And it comes from an insecurity in them. They see something in you that threatens their obviously quite weak sense. of self and so they have to engage in a very specific form of social comparison called downward social comparison to make themselves feel better by making you positioning you as inferior to them but it often means that you start to censor yourself and one of the best parts of friendship is sharing your achievements and also sharing your hard moments if you can't do that what's the point you know what's the point of
genuinely never being able to communicate anything good or bad about your life. So that's number one. That's the competitor. Secondly, there's the friend who always, always has something to say about what you're doing. This next type of toxic friend, we're going to call the critic or the controller. You tell them you're trying a new hobby, they roll their eyes. They tell you it's, you know, it's actually really bad for the influence. environment, that you won't stick with it, that that's kind of lame. You're dating someone new,
while they pick apart their flaws. They talk about how terrible they might be for you, how you could do better. At first, maybe you'll laugh, maybe you'll see them as being protective. Over time, though, this like steady drip of criticism starts to kind of poison everything else. This can also sometimes transform into straight up belittlement, whereby they act as if they always know best. They make you feel smaller, like your decisions are never going to be right. They're never going to be good enough. And again, what's tricky is that this is often disguised as care, right? They might phrase it as, I just don't want to see you get hurt, or I'm only telling you this because I care.
But if they actually cared, or they were mature enough to show they. cared properly, it would actually build you up and give you the confidence to act in your own way. Something like, hey, I support you no matter what, but have you considered this? Or you do what's best for you, you know, I'll always be there if you need me, but have you considered this other thing? Do you see like the shift in framing here? They would be delicate about it. They would be gentle.
That is what a friend should do. And sure, you know, you actually don't want a friend who is always going to agree with you or lie to you. I always say the best sign of a friendship is someone who's going to be ruthlessly honest with you when it is helpful. But if you always disagree with someone in every single thing and if it's always like a power struggle, why are you even friends? Surely there's someone better. In fact, their constant criticism is often a way to try and keep you small and control you and to assert dominance. According to the Gottman Institute, the Gottman Institute is basically like one of the leading marriage and relationship expert groups in the world. They say that criticism is one of their four horsemen of the relationship apocalypse.
It is like one of the biggest signs of relationship breakdown according to them. and it sits alongside contempt, defensiveness and stonewalling. And it's damaging because of how it breaks down trust in a relationship and put someone on edge constantly. Criticism is also a sign that contempt will build on your end or defensiveness will occur. And eventually you will get to that stonewalling stage where you just don't care anymore. If they're going to give their opinion and you don't want to listen to it, why listen to anything they have to say? Okay, so far we've had the competitor and we've had the critic. We are going to take a short break now, but when we return, let's introduce you to our three remaining toxic friendships.
Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black.
people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth
or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud
charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so we have two down, three to go. Are you ready? After the competitor and the critic, we have the gossip. I know we've all met one of these people before.
The funny thing about them is that they can actually be really magnetic at first. You know, they are often the ones who always know what's happening. They seem kind of popular because they know everything in everyone's business. Being close to them can feel like being on the inside. They're often very charismatic. But eventually you realize, hey, I don't think they've talked about themselves once. They only talk about other people. or their opinions about other people.
Or maybe in between all the gossip, they start asking you really personal, really intrusive questions about your life. And then you kind of have this realization, like, huh, if they're talking about everyone else like this, they're probably talking about me too.
I don't think that I'm going to be excluded from this. I'm fairly sure, like, I'm going to be a target. That breaks trust. And once that trust is broken, I think it's nearly impossible to feel safe about opening up again. Friendship thrives on confidentiality and on the belief that your vulnerabilities are held close and careful. So when those get broadcast, any foundation of intimacy like falls apart.
I've also found that with the gossip, they tend to use others' secrets as social currency as a form of money. Like they're a way to gain power for themselves. and so when you're the kind of person who they're sacrificing, like it doesn't feel good. Your secrets are being used to bolster their ego. Eventually all of that kind of social secret mining, it's going to turn on them, it's going to turn on you,
I promise you that. You will realize one day that someone knows something about you that you did not tell them. Who told them that? The gossip. Additionally, I also just think it gets pretty boring talking about other people all the time. feels kind of nasty. You feel the empathy and guilt in your body. It's not to say that none of us,
all of us, like, shouldn't be gossiping. It's actually a very natural human thing. But afterwards, I don't know about you. I feel pretty gross about it. And I always feel the need to be like, oh, you know, but they're such a good person, but this, this, this. So if your friends were someone who's always gossiping and doesn't seem to have that same reaction, sometimes it could say something deeper about your values. You kind of end up thinking like, how in the world do you have the stamina for this? What else are they actually even interested in? What do we even talk about? What's left in their own life? Nothing. It's not necessarily that your secrets are being shared. It might just be that this friendship is kind of boring. This next toxic friendship is actually
pretty hard to spot and this is the victim or the manipulator. The victim is always wronged. Their boss is always unfair to them. Their partner is always cruel. Their other friends are neglectful. At first, you might feel bad for them. Of course you would. Of course you would want to believe them. You know, how awful are these people treating them?
This is so terrible. You want to show them support. But somewhere along the line, you do begin to notice how your needs never really make it into the conversation. And another thing you may notice is that they never seem to take responsibility for their actions. Of course, there are always going to be times when someone needs more support than others within a friendship. It can't always be a 50-50 split.
But if nothing ever resolves, even after your advice, your assistance, your comfort, and it's always a new person for them, well, I don't know, I just don't believe one person's luck is ever that bad. What might happen is that when you finally set a boundary and you say, you know, I can't hang out, I'm super exhausted, or you mention that you feel a little bit unheard or you don't feel great, they flip the script. They might say something like, well, I guess I'm a bad friend. I guess I'll just leave you alone then, leaving you feeling guilty, wondering if you were too harsh, even though all you did was put a boundary in place. In the most extreme cases, I do think there's sometimes veers into gaslighting.
They might turn the narrative so that you're the one at fault for their unhappiness. you become the villain they tell all their other friends about. Maybe converging in a sense into the gossip as well. This constant cycle of trying to do the right thing, guilt, self-doubt, and then exhaustion is super draining and it can leave you kind of unsure of where you stand. You don't want to let them down, but you also want to respect yourself.
I think of all the five toxic friendships. This is the hardest one to walk away. from. Finally, we have the rarest type of all, and that is the friend who was just downright mean. They are the combination of competitive, controlling the gossip and the victim. Sometimes you might struggle to find like literally any redeeming quality about them. Simply put, they are just not very nice to you. They make you the punchline of the jokes in the group setting. They always seem to ruin a perfectly nice time. They are always hostile. They betray you. They flirt with your partner. They out a secret about you. They sabotage you.
This person may be a friend. I also think that they could sometimes be a family member, a sibling, a colleague. To put it frankly, like, you can tell they don't like you. But for some reason, like, they end up remaining in your life. Maybe because you run in the same circles. Maybe because, you know, your lives are so intertwined. maybe their family, maybe they are super nice, sometimes. But their hostility is also super obvious. I think all of these toxic friendships can leave scars. This kind in particular, though, I think can cause attachment wounds very similar to that of a romantic relationship, because it can feel like a full on a front.
Before we talk about the question, you're probably all asking right now, why don't we just walk away? let's just quickly talk about how you can spot if you are in a friendship with this kind of dynamic. One of the hardest parts of recognizing a toxic friendship is that the red flags don't always look obvious. It's not like someone is being like, woohoo, don't be friends with me, I'm going to treat you terribly.
And it's not like when a partner has been awful to you. You know, if they've cheated or were nasty to you, it's pretty clear cut. And we talk about it openly. Like I said, we talk about red flags and relationships all the time. But with friends, it's a lot more subtle. It's the way you shrink a little when you see them come in the room. It's the feeling of relief when your plans get cancelled. It's noticing that after hanging out with them, you feel worse about yourself, not better.
So a concept we might use to refer to this is what we call emotional residue. Even when the conversation is over, even when the hangout is done, that negative sticky residue lingers. You feel gross. You replay what you said. You question if you overreacted. You feel really drained. And over time, that residue actually accumulates as well. It's not just emotionally draining. This actually has a huge impact on how we feel in our bodies. Studies on social stress show that difficult relationships elevate cortisol. They are in. impair sleep, they weaken immunity. One such study published in 2012 by the University of Utah shows the extent of this impact. So in the study, this involved 136 adults and they looked into their relationships with friends, with family, with acquaintances, and they measured both the
positive and negative feeling associated with these bonds. The researchers were basically looking into whether there was any difference in the length of the participant. telemeres. Telomeres are basically the protective caps we have on our chromosomes. Basically, they protect our DNA from damage. They're like helmets for our DNA. It's kind of technical, but basically the shorter, the telomere, the higher the risk of chronic diseases, and a shorter lifespan. And they wanted to see, is there a link between positive and negative relationships and telomere length? What they found was that for the Baticiscius. with a higher number of relationships that had both really high highs and really low lows,
basically a toxic friendship, the shorter the length of the telomeres. Let's dive into these findings a little bit more. They basically suggest that these participants who had been in turbulent, up and down relationships had a higher risk of chronic conditions and stress reactivity compared to people who had obviously all great relationships, but interestingly, also people who just had a lot of pretty terrible relationships. According to the findings of this study, what really mattered here, what really impacted health and telomere length was the intensity of the switch up and was the kind of toxicity meter of these relationships. It was the fact that there were some good
基本上一段有毒的友谊，端粒的长度就越短。让我们再深入探讨一下这些发现。它们基本上表明，与那些显然拥有所有美好关系的相比，经历过动荡、起伏不定的关系的参与者患慢性病和压力反应的风险更高，但有趣的是，那些只经历过很多糟糕关系的人也是如此。根据这项研究的发现，这里真正重要的、真正影响健康和端粒长度的是情绪转变的强度，以及这些关系的“毒性指数”。正是因为其中有一些美好
parts and some bad parts, this emotional push and pull, that was dangerous. That means that even when the friendship isn't necessarily all bad, the inconsistency itself in those friendships is what can take a toll. So to contrast that, let's talk about what a good friendship feels like. And I know this feels kind of silly, but I actually think this is really, really fascinating. And I've never seen anyone talk about this before. In the 90s, researchers Medelson and Abbard proposed a model of six key qualities of strong friendships. These included stimulating companionship, so engaging in enjoyable activities together, help providing each other with support and guidance, intimacy, so sharing personal things with each other. They also included a reliable alliance, so trust,
部分和一些糟糕部分，这种情感上的推拉，才是危险的。这意味着，即使友谊不一定全盘皆输，这些友谊本身的不稳定也会带来代价。因此，与之形成对比的是，让我们来谈谈美好的友谊是什么感觉。我知道这听起来有点傻，但我其实觉得这非常非常吸引人。而且我以前从未见过任何人谈论这个。在 90 年代，研究人员梅德尔森（Medelson）和阿巴德（Abbard）提出了一个关于牢固友谊的六个关键品质的模型。这些包括刺激的陪伴，即一起参与有趣的活动；帮助，即互相提供支持和指导；亲密感，即互相分享私密的事情。它们还包括可靠的联盟，即信任、
emotional security and self-validation. Basically, you encourage each other to feel good about each other and to maintain a positive self-image. That means a good friend celebrates you instead of competing with you. They encourage you instead of criticizing you. They listen to you. They spend time with you. They don't gossip about you. Not only does the research suggest that those who have more of these good, quality, strong friendships tend to rate their
情感安全和自我肯定。基本上，你们鼓励彼此对对方感觉良好，并保持积极的自我形象。这意味着一个好的朋友会庆祝你的成就，而不是与你竞争。他们鼓励你，而不是批评你。他们倾听你。他们陪伴你。他们不八卦你。研究不仅表明，那些拥有更多这些优质、牢固友谊的人往往对生活满意度和幸福感有更高的评价，
life satisfaction and their well-being more highly. But a follow-up study in 2022 found that having these strong friendships is almost protective against stress. So that study it was done in Austria. It found, and it focused on university students during the pandemic, and it found that when they had good friendships, they actually suffered less long term. Obviously, like, that's a different time now, but I still think this plays out on a lot of other scales. You know, they are what keeps us strong. And so if you've got someone who is secretly wants to be your worst enemy and secretly, like, secretly wants to see you fail, hmm, it's not, they're pretty, it's not going to help. Like, it's hard to notice them, but their impact is felt. So, if it's so,
而且 2022 年的一项后续研究发现，拥有这些牢固的友谊几乎可以起到防范压力的作用。该研究是在奥地利进行的。它发现，并重点关注了大流行期间的大学生，结果发现，当他们拥有良好的友谊时，他们在长期受到的伤害其实更少。显然，现在情况不同了，但我仍然认为这在许多其他层面上发挥着作用。你知道，正是它们让我们保持坚强。所以，如果你有一个暗地里想成为你最大敌人、暗地里希望看到你失败的人，嗯，这可帮不上忙。虽然很难注意到他们，但他们的影响是真切存在的。所以，如果说这些有毒的关系会伤害我们是如此
clear that these toxic relationships harm us. Why do we stay? This is complicated. I've asked myself this question many times. So let's talk about it after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
显而易见，我们为什么还要留下来？这很复杂。我自己也问过自己这个问题很多次。所以让我们在短暂的休息后讨论这个问题。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO%。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上拍了金·卡戴珊（Lil Kim）的胸部两次吗？还是坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什跟金·卡戴珊到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格lish（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选你，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。其中包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black.
为了说清楚，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，只是想让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病摆在台面上了，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为有什么年份对黑人来说比这更重要了
people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
人们。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth
已经拥有了它，却还在追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们就像在看计分板一样，生活变成了赢与输。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，当你活在这个世上时，
or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
还是你成为一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为老兄，这是两种不同的意图，绝对是，这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines），在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的不一致之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。你在这份特定的测试中串通篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格（Greg），一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I've talked about this on the podcast a few times throughout the many years. but when I was a kid, I was pretty badly bullied. When I was in primary school, I remember once, like, this group of friends that I really liked. Every weekend I would get my parents to call them on, like, the home phone to have, like, playdates on the weekends. And they would always be like, oh, sorry, like the parents would be like, oh, sorry, she's busy, sorry, they're busy. And then on Monday, I would, like, find out that they were all hanging out because they'd tell me. One time I remember when I was in high school, I was like, to my friends, let's do Secret Santa.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我在过去的很多年里在播客中谈过这个好几次。但当我还是个孩子的时候，我被霸凌得很惨。当我在小学时，我记得有一次，我真的很喜欢的一群朋友。每个周末我都让我父母用家里的座机打电话给他们，以便在周末安排约玩。而他们总是会说，哦，抱歉，或者父母会说，哦，抱歉，她很忙，抱歉，他们很忙。然后到了星期一，我就会发现他们其实都在一起玩，因为他们会告诉我。有一次我记得上高中时，我对朋友们说，我们玩神秘圣诞老人吧。
And they were all like, that's such a stupid idea. And then on the last day of school, I was riding my bike home through the park next to our school. And I saw them there, all like exchanging gifts. And they like saw me and they laughed and they like ducked down. I stayed friends with those people until I left the state. Why did I do that? Part of it is history. If you've been friends for years, you're reliant on them for at least some sense of who you are, or just to not feel alone.
他们都说，这是一个多么愚蠢的主意。然后在那学期的最后一天，我骑着自行车穿过学校旁边公园回家。我看到他们都在那里，互相交换礼物。他们看到我时，还笑了笑，然后蹲了下去。我一直和那些人做朋友，直到我离开这个州。我为什么要这样做？部分原因是历史。如果你已经做了多年的朋友，你就会在某种程度上依赖他们来获得你是谁的感知，或者仅仅是为了不感到孤独。
Cutting ties feels very difficult. You have woven them into your life. And so to untangle that can feel impossible and very, very scary and very isolating. The fear of being left out, the fear of rocking the boat in the broader group, fear of not having anyone else. Like, that's a big factor. Social belonging is a really important human need. and we have been wired to protect it at all costs. But maybe the most significant reason we're drawn back into this time and time again
切断联系感觉非常困难。你已经将他们融入了你的生活。因此，要解开这一切会让人感觉不可能、非常非常可怕且非常孤立。害怕被排挤，害怕在更大的群体中掀起波澜，害怕没有其他人。这真是一个重要因素。社会归属感是人类一项非常重要的需求，
is what that study said earlier. The hope, the up and down relationships. Toxic friendships are never 100% bad. There are flashes of joy and kindness and nostalgia. Every single person has redeeming qualities. Psychologists have a name for this. It's called intermittent reinforcement. When good and bad are mixed kind of unpredictably,
我们天生就会不惜一切代价去保护它。但也许我们一次又一次被拉回这种关系中最显著的原因，
The bond becomes even harder to break because you keep chasing the next good moment and you hope that it will be enough to outweigh the bad. We see this play out in gambling, in addiction, toxic romance relationships, the push, the pool, the cycle of chasing the highs. It's not weakness that keeps us stuck, but actually a very human desire to preserve the connection. And this kind of cycle makes it really hard to walk away because, How do you know when someone's had too many chances? It's a very agonizing question. The truth is, I'm not going to be able to give you an answer. There isn't a universal number.
就像刚才那项研究所说的那样：希望，起伏不定的关系。有毒的友谊绝不是 100% 糟糕的。其中会有快乐、善良和怀旧的闪光。每个人都有可以救赎的品质。心理学家对此有一个专有名词，叫做间歇性强化。当美好与糟糕以某种不可预测的方式混合时，
Instead, the better question to ask is, what have they already done with the chances you have given them? Because the fact that you're considering the question means it's not a one-off event, it's likely become a pattern. So when you bring up your feelings, do they listen or do they dismiss you? Do they take responsibility or do they shift blame? Do they make changes or do they repeat it again and again? And if this was a romantic partner, would you tolerate this pattern?
这种纽带就变得更加难以打破，因为你一直在追逐下一个美好的时刻，并希望它足以抵消糟糕的时刻。我们看到这种现象在赌博、成瘾、有毒的浪漫关系中上演：推、拉、追逐高潮的循环。让我们深陷其中的不是软弱，而是人类对维持连接的极度渴望。这种循环让人很难抽身离开，因为你怎么知道一个人什么时候已经得到了足够多的机会？这是一个极其痛苦的问题。事实是，我无法给你一个答案。没有一个普遍适用的数字。
Healthy relationships aren't perfect. They're not defined by the absence of conflict, but the ability to repair this conflict. This is known in psychology as rupture and rebellion. theory. A lot of really long-lasting relationships have really hard moments. The fact that you band together and fix it and repair it shows love and commitment. If someone shows willingness to repair after a rupture through apologies, change behavior, consistency, yeah, they may deserve another chance. But if every chance is met with empty apologies, excuses, or if they just go straight back to what they have done before. The question may become not how many chances should I
相反，更好的问题是：对于你给过他们的机会，他们都已经做了什么？因为你已经在考虑这个问题，这意味着这不是一次性的事件，它很可能已经成为一种模式。所以，当你提出自己的感受时，他们是会倾听还是会打发你？他们是承担责任还是推卸责任？他们是做出了改变还是不断重复？如果这是一个浪漫的伴侣，你会容忍这种模式吗？
give them, but why am I still offering them? If you find yourself at this point, it's very difficult. Friendships aren't built on contracts or ceremonies like marriages or jobs. They can fade in and out and they can evolve silently and that can make knowing when to walk away very confusing. So I'm going to outline some steps that you can take to address a top of the time. toxic friendship, starting with this first one. If you feel physically and emotionally safe, clarity is always the first step. It's very easy to fantasize about just disappearing, but sometimes what feels like toxicity can actually stem just from a lack of awareness, they just don't know how you're feeling.
健康的友谊并非完美。它们的定义不在于没有冲突，而在于修复冲突的能力。这在心理学中被称为破裂与修复理论。许多非常持久的关系都有过非常艰难的时刻。你们团结在一起并修复它的事实，展现了爱与承诺。如果有人在关系破裂后表现出通过道歉、改变行为、保持一致性来进行修复的意愿，是的，他们可能值得再给一次机会。但如果每一次机会都伴随着空洞的道歉、借口，或者他们只是直接回到以前的做法。问题可能不再是我应该给他们
And trust me, ghosting isn't a good solution. I've done that to a friend. I really didn't think I could repair things with for a lot of reasons. and despite that, I really regret it. I regret it actually a lot. At the time, it felt right, but I wish that we'd had a chance to maybe just maybe been able to hash things out.
多少次机会，而是为什么我还在给他们机会？如果你发现自己到了这个地步，那就非常困难了。友谊不是建立在合同或仪式上的，不像婚姻或工作。它们可以逐渐淡去，也可以在无声中演变，这会让什么时候该抽身离开变得非常令人困惑。因此，我将概述一些你可以采取的步骤来应对这种有毒的友谊，从第一步开始。如果你觉得在身体和情感上是安全的，那么清晰总是第一步。想象一下直接消失很容易，但有时看似有毒的情况实际上可能只是源于缺乏意识，他们只是不知道你的感受。
Of course, when we approach someone with accusations like, you're always so negative, or you're such a bad friend, they're going to get defensive, they're going to turn it back on you. But when we frame our concerns around our own feelings, we leave the door open for, again, repair. That might sound like,
相信我，人间蒸发（ghosting）并不是一个好解决方案。我曾经对一个朋友这样做过。出于很多原因，我真的认为我无法修复与她的关系，尽管如此，我真的很后悔。实际上我非常后悔。当时觉得这样做是对的，但我希望我们有机会，哪怕只有一点点机会，能够把事情说清楚。
you know, when you cancel last minute, I feel unimportant. I know you don't mean it that way, but this makes me feel like I don't matter. The focus is on the impact it had on you, not their character. And this shifts the conversation from blame to possibility. Sometimes people just don't realize how their behavior lands. They just don't know. They're used to interacting with people in a different way. And in those cases, like a simple conversation, can actually change the
当然，当我们带着指责去接近某人时，比如“你总是那么消极”或者“你是个这么糟糕的朋友”，他们就会开启防御机制，把矛头转回你身上。但当我们把担忧围绕着我们自己的感受时，我们就会为再次修复留出大门。那听起来可能像是：
entire dynamic. Let me tell you this. When you are overwhelmed, angry, frustrated, lashing out is the easiest thing you can do. But oh my gosh, in the long term, it feels a lot better to handle things maturely. And I'm telling you, like when you get to a moment where you realize, hey, like, I handled this so much better than I would have before, like, I'm so proud of talking with them about this. You feel great about yourself. Like, you kind of even want to talk to them about it and be like, hey, we handled that so well. Like, look at us growing as people. It's a good moment. Really start there. I implore you to start at that point of clarity. If the behavior doesn't change, that's when boundaries come in. Here's something worth emphasizing.
你知道的，当你最后一秒取消计划时，我觉得自己很不重要。我知道你不是那个意思，但这让我觉得自己无足轻重。重点在于它对你产生的影响，而不是他们的性格。这把对话从指责转向了可能性。有时人们只是没有意识到他们的行为会带来什么影响。他们只是不知道。他们习惯了用不同的方式与人交往。在那种情况下，一次简单的对话其实就能改变
Boundaries are not meant to be punishments. They are actually instructions for how you want to be treated. There is a famous quote that I love that says, boundaries are the distance at which I can love you, and still love myself simultaneously. I think that's profound. They're not walls to, like, shut people out. They're actually guidelines that allow you to stay connected if the other person is willing to respect them. A boundary is, I can't keep talking to you
整个动态。让我告诉你这个：当你不知所措、愤怒、沮丧时，大发雷霆是你最容易做的事。但天哪，从长远来看，成熟地处理事情感觉要好得多。我告诉你，当你到达这样一个时刻，你意识到，嘿，我比以前处理得好多了，嘿，我为自己能和他们谈论这件事感到骄傲。你会对自我感觉良好。甚至，你可能还想和他们谈谈，然后说，嘿，我们把那件事处理得真好。看我们作为人都在成长。这是一个美好的时刻。真正从那里开始。我恳请你从那个清晰的起点开始。如果行为没有改变，那就是边界发挥作用的时候了。这里有一点值得强调：
if you make me feel judged afterwards. Or when you make those jokes in front of other people, I need to step back. The boundaries need to be specific. There needs to be cause and effect. You did this. I'm responding this way. They cannot be like vague demands to like, you know, try harder with me or be nicer.
边界不是为了惩罚。它们实际上是你希望如何被对待的说明书。有一句我很喜欢的名言说：“边界是我可以爱你，同时也能继续爱我自己的距离。”我觉得这很有深意。它们不是把人关在门外的墙。如果你愿意尊重它们，它们实际上是让你保持连接的准则。一个边界是：如果你让我觉得事后遭到评判，我就无法继续跟你谈话了。或者当你在其他人面前开那些玩笑时，我需要退一步。边界必须是具体的。必须有因果关系。你做了这个，我这样回应。它们不能是含糊不清的要求，比如“对我好一点”或者“对我和善一点”。
They need to be specific. I need you to make plans with me. I need you to honor out commitments. I need you to speak positively about me around other people. If the person in question then decides to disregard these boundaries, it is really important to act. It's the hardest part. And it doesn't mean like a dramatic ultimatum or a fight.
它们需要具体。我需要你和我一起做计划。我需要你遵守我们的承诺。我需要你在别人面前说我的好话。如果相关人员随后决定无视这些边界，采取行动就非常重要。这是最困难的部分。这并不意味着戏剧性的最后通牒或争吵。
It can simply mean reducing how much time you spend together. or choosing not to share vulnerable information or letting the friendship kind of just move to the background a little bit. A boundary is a contract. If you say a boundary is a non-negotiable, but then allowed it to be crossed without consequences, you know, it doesn't really work.
它可能仅仅意味着减少你们在一起的时间，或者选择不分享敏感信息，或者让这段友谊稍微退居二幕。边界是一份合同。如果你说一个边界是不可协商的，但随后又允许它被跨越而没有任何后果，你知道，这其实不管用。
It just kind of becomes like a suggestion. So you need to be ready to teach people sometimes how to treat you, which everyone knew. But again, sometimes people just are used to, different things. They have a different way of seeing things. They have a different culture. They have a different personality. So make sure that you have a clear boundary that may actually help them treat you better. I would also advise that you lean on other friends for their perspective, specifically ones that you
它只会变成一种建议。所以你需要准备好教别人有时如何对待你，虽然每个人都懂。但话说回来，有时候人们只是习惯了不同的事物。他们有不同的看法。他们有不同的文化。他们有不同的个性。所以确保你有一个明确的边界，这实际上可能有助于他们更好地对待你。我还要建议你向其他朋友征求他们的看法，特别是那些你
trust. We've talked about how friends can be mirrors to ourselves. Toxic friends can warp that mirror, make it feel like we're being unreasonable or selfish. Talking it through with supportive people gives you that reality. check. It allows you to practice possible responses in advance as well. Toxic dynamics often come with gas lighting or deflection, so rehearsing how you'll stay calm can really help. For example, if you know they're going to say like you're overreacting, practice saying to a friend, I hear you, but this is still important to me. And I think maybe most importantly to note, give yourself permission to step away if you don't want to be there anymore. Friendships
信任的朋友。我们讨论过朋友如何成为我们的镜子。有毒的朋友会扭曲这面镜子，让你觉得很不讲道理或很自私。与支持你的人一起探讨能给你这种现实检验。它还能让你提前练习可能的反应。有毒的动态通常伴随着煤气灯效应或推卸责任，所以排练如何保持冷静真的很有帮助。例如，如果你知道他们会说你反应过度，那就练习对朋友说：我听到你的话了，但这对我来说仍然很重要。我想也许最重要的一点是，如果你不想再待在那里了，给自己允许抽离的权限。友谊
are valuable, not all of them are worth preparing. Sometimes the healthiest thing is simply just to let nature take its course. Just let the person fade out. That might not always be possible. Something I always get asked is like, I have this terrible person that I'm friends with, but we are in a friendship group. We have all these friends, all these connections. connections, it's going to get messy, what do I do? I think in those moments, the goal shifts
很有价值，但并非所有友谊都值得修复。有时最健康的做法就是让自然顺其自然。让这个人逐渐淡出。这并不总是可能的。我经常被问到的一个问题是：我有一个很糟糕的朋友，但我们在一个朋友圈里。我们有所有的朋友，所有的联系，事情会变得很乱，我该怎么办？我认为在那些时刻，目标从结束友谊转变为了
from ending the friendship to managing the dynamic. I'm going to be honest. It's going to be awkward. It's going to be a little bit uncomfortable at times, purely because the dynamic has changed, but I promise you you can handle discomfort. It's okay. But it is really important to avoid trying to recruit the whole group and ask them to take sides. This is like a very natural instinct. Do not force people to see your perspective. They will naturally form their own opinions. Your job isn't to convince them.
管理动态。说实话，这会很尴尬。有时会有点不舒服，纯粹是因为动态已经改变了，但我向你保证，你可以应对这种不适。没关系。但非常重要的是，要避免试图拉拢整个群体并要求他们选边站。这是一种非常自然的本能。不要强迫别人看到你的视角。他们自然会形成自己的观点。你的工作不是说服他们。
Don't avoid the situation either. Avoidance can often isolate you more than the toxic person ever did and it can be part of their toolkit. Instead, go on with a game plan. you will stay polite. You will keep things neutral. You will focus your energy on the friends who support you. Because if they are still good friends, they can actually be friends with two people at once. I know this is really hard sometimes because you're like, how do you not see what they've done to me and how awful they were to me? Just trust me, they're going to figure it out. They will figure it out.
也不要回避这种情况。回避往往比那个有毒的人更能孤立你，而且这可能是他们工具箱的一部分。相反，制定一个行动计划：你将保持礼貌。你将保持中立。你将把精力集中在支持你的朋友身上。因为如果他们仍然是好朋友，他们其实可以同时和两个人做朋友。我知道有时这真的很难，因为你会想：你怎么看不到他们对我的所作所为，他们对我有多糟糕？相信我，他们会明白的。他们会明白的。
I, one of my best friends, had this falling out with a mutual friend of ours. And I stayed friends with this other person for a little while because it was kind of uncomfortable for me to walk away. It wasn't my fight. Oh, she didn't say anything. She was great to me about it. She was like, you stay friends with them. And I figured out exactly after a while what had caused their friendship breakup, you know,
我的一位好朋友曾与我们的一位共同朋友闹翻。我跟这个人继续做了一会儿朋友，因为走开对我来说有点尴尬。这不是我的战斗。哦，她什么也没说。她对此对我很好。她说：你继续和他们做朋友吧。过了一段时间，我很快就弄清楚了导致他们友谊破裂的原因，
sooner, soon enough. It always happens. This is advice I gave to my friend, like literally the other. other day, who is dealing with like a big group dynamic where one person obviously doesn't like her but hasn't said anything directly. Approach those interactions like nothing is wrong. If they haven't confronted you, even though you know they're talking about it behind your back, it's still none of your business. I need you to use every fiber in your body to be kind, to be normal. To you, there is no problem. If they want to bring a problem to you,
足够快。这种情况总是会发生。这是我前几天才给我的朋友的建议，她正在处理一个大型群体动态，其中一个人明显不喜欢她，但没有直接说出来。以若无其事的心态对待这些互动。如果他们没有与你对质，即使你知道他们在你背后议论，那也依然不管你的事。我需要你用你全身心的力量去保持善良、保持正常。对你来说，没有问题。如果他们想把问题带给你，
great, but that's their business. You are showing the group, you are showing yourself that you are bigger than the drama. That is the most powerful way that you can manage this situation. Now, let's talk about the friendship breakup. I feel like we've kind of been snaking our way to this moment where the explosion happens. We know that friendship breakups do not get the same attention as romantic breakups, and yet we know they can be just as hard. it's important that you allow yourself to be sad about this you're allowed to grieve this person
很好，但那是他们的事情。你在向群体展示，向你自己展示，你比这些抓马（drama）更伟大。这是管理这种情况最有力的途径。现在，让我们谈谈友谊的破裂。我觉得我们好像一直在慢慢走向这个爆发的时刻。我们知道，友谊的分手没有像恋爱分手那样受到同样的关注，然而我们知道它们同样艰难。重要的是，你要允许自己为此感到悲伤，你被允许为这个人
and what the future you really thought you had with them it's so romantic because friendship is romantic at times you do imagine a future but i think it's really refreshing just to see what space that opens up for you toxic friendships take up a lot of energy they take up a lot of time and space in our mind so we when they fade, that space is suddenly yours again. Use it. Text that old friend that you've lost touch with. Join a book club, join a running group, do a trivia night, do a pottery class, dive back into your hobbies and the things that make you feel like you again. Honestly, it's like a breakup. After a breakup, you've got to kind of curate your social life all over again. And that
以及你真正以为和他们拥有的未来感到难过。这很浪漫，因为友谊有时就是浪漫的，你确实会想象一个未来。但我认为，看到这为自己打开了什么样的空间，真的是一件让人耳目一新的事。有毒的友谊占用了大量的精力和时间，以及我们脑海中的空间，所以当它们淡去时，那个空间突然又属于你了。去利用它吧。给那个失去联系的老朋友发短信。加入读书俱乐部，加入跑步小组，参加问答之夜，上陶艺课，重新投入到你的爱好和那些让你重新找回自己的事情中去。老实说，这就像分手一样。分手后，你得重新规划你的社交生活，这意味着
means you get to choose what feels good, what energizes you, what you want more of. Losing a friendship knocks your confidence so hard. It's so conflicting. You know it's for the best. You feel like a bad person implicitly. Sometimes you have regrets. So just investing all of that energy back into yourself can really help. It's also so empowering to celebrate the upgrade. And I don't want to come across as cold or dismissive or insensitive, but they're kind of losing the better person here. They're losing you. You know, they're losing the person that gave them a bunch of chances that talked them through their behavior, that celebrated them, that loved them. For whatever reason, the friendship didn't work out. You guys didn't gel. So that doesn't mean that you didn't try your
你可以选择什么感觉良好，什么能给你能量，你想要更多什么。失去一段友谊对你的自信心打击太大了。这太矛盾了。你知道这是为了最好。你潜意识里觉得自己是个坏人。有时你会感到后悔。所以把所有的精力重新投入到自己身上真的很有帮助。庆祝升级也同样充满力量。我不想显得冷酷、冷漠或不敏感，但其实是他们在失去更好的人。他们失去了你。你知道的，他们失去了那个给他们很多机会、开导他们的行为、赞美他们、爱他们的人。不管出于什么原因，这段友谊没有成功。你们没有合拍。但这并不意味着你没有付出
hardest and that you're not still at catch. you're not losing in this situation. You cannot be friends with every single person you've ever met for the rest of your life. That is actually a gain. It's a gain when you realize that someone can't keep up with your emotional bandwidth, can't keep up with you, doesn't care about you the way you care about them, as someone who had so many experiences when they were a teenager,
最大的努力，而且你依然是个优秀的“捕获物”（catch）。在这场局中你没有输。你不可能余生都和见过的每个人做朋友。这其实是一个收获。当你意识到某人无法跟上你的情感带宽，无法跟上你的步伐，不像你在乎他们那样在乎你时，这是一个收获。作为一个在青少年时期、
when they were younger, when they were in university, where they would try very, very hard. I would always try so hard to be the friend that everyone wanted to be friends with and I would put so much into my friendships and I would love them so much and do the exciting things for their birthdays and shout dinners and, you know, be at their runs and celebrate them. Some people just don't appreciate that. And the thing is, is that I waited a long time
年轻时、上大学时经历过很多事情的人，我曾经非常非常努力。我总是极力想成为每个人都想与之交友的朋友，我会将大量心血投入到我的友谊中，我会非常深爱他们，为他们的生日做激动人心的事情，请他们吃晚餐，你知道的，去参加他们的跑步活动并为他们庆祝。有些人就是不懂得欣赏这一点。问题在于，我等待了很久，
and now I have the people that do. So I can tell you that there are. out there. I was talking to like a family member of mine who's a lot younger than me, who was like going through a really hard time at school. And I just was like, I totally get where you're coming from. I spent like the first two decades of my life without any real friends with like one real friend. And then suddenly like I entered my mid-20s and everyone like came out of the woodwork. Everyone was like, I suddenly just met these amazing people. And the same way I didn't settle in a romantic relationship, I didn't settle when it came to my friendships either. And now I just
现在我有了那些懂得欣赏的人。所以我可以告诉你，他们就在外面。我曾和我的一个比我小得多的家庭成员交谈，她在学校经历了一段非常艰难的时期。我只是说，我完全理解你的感受。我生命中的前二十年都没有真正的朋友，只有一个真正的朋友。然后突然间我进入了二十岁中期，每个人都从各个地方冒出来了。每个人都说，我突然遇到了这些了不起的人。就像我在恋爱关系中没有将就一样，在友谊方面我也没有将就。现在我只是
feel like I have been rewarded for my suffering and for my times when I didn't get what I wanted in terms of friendship. And I truly believe that that happens for people. And that holding out for good friends is just, again, like holding out for good relationships. So I'm wishing you the best of luck. I hope this episode has brought you some clarity when it comes to these relationships. I hope it has given you a sense that stepping away is not necessarily a bad thing, is not and does not make you a bad person. And that, yeah, these people exist and they suck. it's okay to like not want to be friends with them anymore. So I hope this episode helped. I hope you learned something from it. I want to thank our wonderful, wonderful researcher Libby Colbert
觉得我为我的痛苦以及那些在友谊方面没有得到我想要的东西的时期得到了回报。我真的相信这种事会发生在人们身上。坚持等待好朋友，再次强调，就像等待美好的恋情一样。所以我祝你们好运。希望这一集能为你带来一些关于这些关系的清晰认识。我希望它让你觉得抽身离开并不一定是一件坏事，并不是，也不会让你成为一个坏人。而且，是的，这些人的确存在，而且他们很烂。不想再和他们做朋友是没问题的。所以我希望这一集有所帮助。希望你从中学到了一些东西。我要感谢我们非常非常优秀的 پژوه员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）
for her contributions to this episode. If you have made it this far, I want you to leave a little comment down below showing some love for a non-toxic friend in your life. Let's show people that they still exist. I want to shout up my friend Aaron. Aaron is like, the other member of this podcast. I feel like if you've been around for a while, you will have heard her name quite a few times. She's been on the podcast like twice. I had such a great weekend with Erin last weekend when I went and surprised her. So I just want to give a shout out to her. You know, we didn't become friends until I was like 22 and I've never felt so much love from another person who I was not like either a family member of or dating. So those friends do exist and I want to give her a
为本集做出的贡献。如果你听到了这里，我希望你在下方留下一条小评论，为你生活中的一个无毒的朋友表达一些爱意。让我们向人们展示他们依然存在。我想大声感谢我的朋友亚伦（Aaron）。亚伦就像是这个播客的另一个成员。我觉得如果你关注了一段时间，你就会听到她的名字好几次了。她上过这个播客大约两次。上周末我去给亚伦一个惊喜时，我们度过了一个多么美好的周末。所以我只想大声感谢她。你知道的，直到我大约 22 岁时我们才成为朋友，除了家人或恋爱对象之外，我从未从另一个人身上感受到如此多的爱。所以这样的朋友确实存在，如果你有这种感觉，我希望你能在下面的评论区向这样的人表达感谢。
shout out and hopefully you can give a shout out to someone like that in the comments below if you feel called to do so make sure that you are following along or subscribed wherever you are listening whether that is on youtube apple spotify the iheart radio app make sure to leave a five-star review if you feel called to do so and follow us on instagram at that psychology podcast someone was asking me the other day why it's not the psychology of your 20s um i'm fairly sure either that name was taken or it was just too long. So there you go. There's your answer.
确保你在收听的任何地方都进行关注或订阅，无论是在 YouTube、Apple、Spotify 还是 iHeartRadio 应用上，如果你愿意，请留下五星好评，并在 Instagram 上关注我们：@thatpsychologypodcast。前几天有人问我为什么不叫“The Psychology of Your 20s”（你二十岁的心理学），嗯，我相当确定要么那个名字被占用了，要么就是太长了。所以，这就是答案。
That psychology podcast, it is. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself in the face of maybe a toxic friendship. I believe in you. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
就是那个心理学播客。但直到下次之前，保持安全，保持善良，面对可能存在的有毒友谊时，对你自己温柔一点。我相信你。我们很快就会再次交谈。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. he's going to get what he deserves. We always say that
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他将得到应得的下场。我们总是说，
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我是个重大时刻。84 年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格lish（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选你，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的朋友以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
那真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为有什么年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？
You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional.
你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一位持有执照的专业人士对话。
knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他知道自己在做什么。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证是由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子以留下评论。